hi
i'm lynne langet cloud architect and
developer
and the first google developer expert or
gde
lately i've been working with
bioinformatics clients
building cloud-based genomic skill
pipelines
in this talk i'm going to talk about
patterns
for implementing effective pipelines on
the google cloud platform
there are four parts what is needed
in this area why do we need to have
patterns and how do you learn them how
are you going to use
pattern information and how can you
learn more
first we need to understand the scale
and scope of the problem
in my work as a cloud architect i've
worked some pretty big data sets
in fintech in new york and london in ad
tech in la
but genomic scale data sets are a whole
new level the amount of data that's
being generated
by mostly human genomic analysis
requires new patterns for building
effective analysis pipelines on the
cloud now when i talk about scale what
do i mean can i give an example
yeah i will a recent client that i've
been working with is the broad institute
at mit and harvard
on average they've been putting in
17 terabytes per day into the google
cloud
this is an astounding number think about
it in your own work
in data pipelining are any of you
working
at anywhere close to the scale yet if
not i think you will be
even if you're not in genomics and the
reason for this is the amount of data
that's being generated i've had other
projects in the iot
area in ad tech and they come close to
this
but genomics is at the cutting edge
so what are the challenges in building
effective
gcp pipelines at this scale well there's
a lot of them
first cloud practices which services
should our researchers use should they
use virtual machines
should they use bigquery should they use
higher level services
how are they going to understand devops
practices
how are they going to work with
configuration as code
and really importantly how are they
going to learn about service cost
control
you can make a very expensive mistake
very fast with this amount of data
speaking of data how are we going to try
out and learn
these services the data that many of my
clients work with
is personally identifiable human health
data
how are we going to work with down
sample data sets these data sets are
huge they have
three billion letters and they do
analysis across the genome
speaking of the genome researchers
really want to work with genomics
examples most of the examples in
learning cloud services are generic
hello world and that really doesn't
resonate with my customers
on top of that in genomics
there is a increasing approach
moving towards tools and libraries such
as
jtk the genomic analysis toolkit and the
widdle or wdl workflow definition
language
the next flow library in language nf
and galaxy project there are many others
so what i've done to address this
knowledge gap is i've created an open
source course on github
it is 100 free because it's on github
and it consists of notes markdown pages
screencasts code examples and sample
data
importantly all of the examples use
genomic data
it's called gcp for bioinformatics
so this course introduces researchers to
working with
raw google cloud infrastructure or
systems for genomic analysis built on
the google cloud
including teradot bio from the road
institute in berlin
variant spark library from csiro
bioinformatics in sydney australia
next flow i o from the group in europe
galaxy project which is global
and others now to get an understanding
of the complexity
let's first consider batch compute for
analysis
if you start at the bottom of the
diagram although today we're talking
about the google cloud
many of my researchers are faced with
the additional complexity of
collaborating
with researchers who work with a
different vendor cloud so we have a
number of public vendor clouds
on top of that they'll build their
analysis on
clusters of virtual machines and
increasingly containers
and on top of that many of them are now
starting to use orchestration layers
such as spark or kubernetes
on top of all that cloud infrastructure
researchers are often using these
bioinformatics tools and libraries that
i previously mentioned such as tarot dot
bio nex flow galaxy and more
those libraries have associated
languages such as whittle wdl
cwl common workflow language next flow
nf or ga
and those tools often have orchestration
layers
such as cromwell for terror.bio or mini
widow
pipelines api is actually a google api
that works
in conjunction with a lot of these
higher level libraries
does this look confusing well it is
there's a lot of different tools and
libraries to understand it's one of the
reasons that i made this course to break
all these services into parts and pieces
so that they can be
learned and understood individually and
then combined effectively
now in addition to batch compute
you'll notice a similar but not
identical kind of pattern here and this
is interactive analysis
now this keys around the center square
in the center of the center square the i
python notebook or i
p y and b it is becoming a pattern in
genomics
to create reproducible research in the
form of a jupiter notebook
and so an important pattern in
pipelining
is scaling those notebook environments
using jupiter hub
or google collabs so again there are a
number of parts and pieces to working
with these pipelining infrastructures
and my course covers all of these on the
google cloud
so drilling into the highlights of what
my course covers
it really is designed to be consumed the
way that you actually work with the
cloud there is a level zero
for setting up your account and setting
up cost control level one is files and
data because of course we're computing
on files
and i cover core services such as
storage buckets google cloud storage
i cover public data sets that are
available such as thousand genomes and
other data sets
for genomics that have restricted access
services like bigquery
which provides serverless sql querying
on top of
files and can be used for genomic type
files such as vcf or variant calling
format
also i cover higher level services such
as teradot bio
data sets
in the compute area i cover topics such
as virtual machines
running containers of course clusters of
each of these and also include
information about
serverless or functions at the workflow
level
but also the google life sciences api
which is called the pipelines api
next flow and higher level services such
as tarot dot bio
additionally to cover the interactive
pattern
i have information about working with
and setting up jupiter notebook
environments on the google cloud
platform
i also include modern devops practices
such as
cicd or continuous integration and
continuous deployment
and i have information about machine
learning that's specific to genomics
covering examples of libraries like deep
variant
tensorflow io and google nucleus
another aspect of the course design is
that my examples
are designed to be quick one of the
challenges that i found when i was
learning
genomics tools as a cloud architect as
many of examples
reflected real world in real world can
be
huge amounts of data so a hello world
can take
minutes or hours or even days to run
and that just wasn't a way that i wanted
to work
so i provide example data
and i provide specific steps to try out
each service
my course is designed to run on a trial
google cloud platform account
and if you run with my example data sets
it should be at nearly no cost i never
pay more than a dollar or two
and importantly most examples run in
five minutes or less
so you can quickly get up and running
and you can find out if the service is
going to work for your particular
analysis
needs another aspect to the way i've
designed the course
is i've designed it at three levels for
each of the service
areas so for example for files for data
for compute so on and so forth
so the three levels are infrastructure
as a service
and this is for researchers who want to
set up control and manage
everything the level of data for example
they might want to set up their own
rdbms or relational database they might
want to set up their own
no sql environment on virtual machines
or on google cloud storage buckets at
the compute layer
these researchers would prefer to set up
their own clusters of google compute
engine virtual machines or docker images
on
google kubernetes engine
there are other researchers who would
prefer to work at the platform level
they would rather run their analysis
over managed services
and let google handle more of the
underlying infrastructure
so data this looks like data lakes that
are running on gcs buckets
google cloud storage buckets and use of
public reference genomics data
at the compute layer this often
manifests by using services such as
dataproc
or the google life sciences api which
efficiently handles orchestration of
groups of virtual machines
allowing the researchers to dynamically
spin up and spin down
compute resources and it allows them to
take advantage of
aspects that are specific to google
cloud such as preemptable instances
so that they can save lots of money
which is really important at this scale
still other researchers prefer to work
at the software as a service level
and one example of this is using the
terra.bio system
which is a web ui that was designed by
the road institute in verily
that currently runs on top of the google
cloud platform
in this case rather than interacting
with the
gcp console or using tools such as
gsutil
my researchers will go to the tarot.bio
platform
and they can access both their own data
and publicly available genomic data
through the tara ui
also they can spin up and spin down
jupiter notebook instances
and compute clusters that run on top of
the
life sciences api through the web ui
now that's a lot of different areas to
think about so
i think at this point will be helpful if
we actually take
just a brief look at the course on
github
in this demo i want to show you my open
source
course that i built gcp for
bioinformatics
so first we're going to go out to the
site on github
and this is where all the artifacts for
the course are located
you can see that the course is organized
by topic area
and it's set up in folders so they're
numbered
in a logical order you would of course
start by setting up your gcp account
then you would work with files of data
then you would work with virtual
machines docker containers or functions
so compute
and multiple instances you may add
machine learning
you also might use code and cloud
service tools
such as continuous integration and
continuous deployment
container registries and other tools
in each section the organization is set
up as follows
at the beginning of each section there's
a readme so there's a main readme
i'll just scroll down here and you can
see
that i've consistently used emoji
throughout
the repository to make it easier to scan
you can see the list here
as it says this repo includes content
you can read
watch or run so you can read pages of
the repo you can think of them as notes
you can watch linked youtube screencasts
or demonstrations
you can try out the computational
examples using jupiter notebooks
there are linked github repos and
there are additional advanced topic
links at the end of each section
on each page there will be a linked
youtube video so you just click the
graphic
to go to the video if you prefer to
learn by watching screencasts
you can simply go to the playlist that
i've created and linked
and as you can see there are 27
different short screencasts mostly
around five minutes some of them are six
or seven
that cover the topics via demonstrations
now just to get an idea of how each
topic is set up
we'll take a look at one topic area just
so you can understand the structure
which is consistent throughout the
course
so here we have in the files and data
section
in that section we have a topic called
sql questions and this topic
uh is covering using the bigquery
service
with a bioinformatics or genomic example
so you can see first there's a little
explanation about it
and then these uh notes pages are very
action oriented in the design in that
they're
created so that you can actually try out
the service
with a genomics example within five to
ten minutes and get a result that
quickly as well
it's a little bit unusual it's one of
the reasons i made the course because
i've seen a lot of
bioinformatics examples that take hours
to run
and i really in course design wanted to
create examples that would
cost basically nothing to try out
because of the tiny sizes of the sample
data sets
and would be just really quick and easy
now in the case of bigquery
i've included a number of screenshots in
this
notes page because i'm assuming that for
most people taking the course this will
be a new service
so you can see for example i've used
this
screenshot in the beginning of this page
now this page actually is a link out
to an additional course and this is a
course on using the
ansi sql language against a sample
genomic data set
and if you just go down the page this
page is a little bit longer than some of
the other pages
is it's a three-part course and you can
see for example
we've got sql queries here that you can
actually run
now just to show you how this is
intended to be used
the course is designed to be used with a
trial gcp actual account so you can
run the lessons and and learn by doing
so for this particular one if i scroll
way down here for a second
and i'll just stop here this is an
example using a concept called a self
join
on a very very small but a domain
specific
example and and so the idea here is to
return a hierarchy
and the lesson as you can see
is write a sql query to return the
grandparent category of
glycine binding so um to show you the
environment where you work with this
this is
bigquery in gcp and for this course i've
created
a publicly available really small
sample data set so you can see here i'll
click on this experiments table
and i can actually preview it and it has
just five rows
again really tiny examples here
one of the concepts as i mentioned in
talking about this course is
that you can explore these services with
examples that come from genomics that
are tiny so you can do it basically at
no cost
and in just a shorter amount of time so
the course is completely on github so
it's completely free
it's completely open source i really
welcome
any suggestions from the community the
best way to do that is through pull
requests sort of the typical
github process and i really look forward
to the contributions and the feedback of
the bioinformatics research community
it's lynn langett and of course is gcp
for bioinformatics
thank you